in our series profiles in service we
introduced you to Americans who dedicate
their lives to helping others this
morning we meet the Easter family they
have a tradition of service stretching
back at least 100 years the three Easter
sisters are the fourth generation of
military members on both sides of the
family we recently spoke with the Easter
family at the United States Military
Academy at West Point my dad never even
really talked about the military because
he had three daughters and didn't want
to pressure any of us into going to the
military if we didn't want to for the
Easter sisters answering the call to
service felt natural service just means
playing your part to protect your
country and the people that you love
when I was younger my parents are
telling me like served with the
servant's heart and not just means
sacrificing I can always be grateful but
the trio does it with an individual
twist each got accepted into a different
military service Academy Corey is an
alumnus of the United States Air Force
Academy Maddie the youngest is in her
sophomore year at West Point and Adrian
who couldn't join us because she's
studying for exams will graduate from
the Naval Academy in May Adrian's a
nuclear engineers at the Naval Academy
so she's trying really hard to finish
our Perce senior year and she's very
determined I think we grew up with a lot
of structure too in our house just very
disciplined and a good way so I think
just the military was I mean just
natural sounds like Stacy was the
original commander drill sergeant stacy
drilled into her daughters that they
didn't have to conform to traditional
gender stereotypes corey you told us
that your parents never treated you or
your sisters like girls right our
parents never raised us like the typical
girl you know they never said that we
couldn't do anything of any sorts they
never limited us my dad too like he
would just look at me like any of the
other people and say you can you can
lead men why not dad Luke flew f-15
strike Eagles for the Air Force during
two tours in the Middle East in 1991 and
93 he retired and became a commercial
pilot oldest daughter Cory followed him
into the
air force paving the way for her sisters
2020 that's a cool year to graduate yes
junga sister Maddie apprehensive at
first found her home here at West Point
just seeing my sisters go through all
the trials and tribulations that made
them the people they are today I was
afraid of that was intimidated by that
but there are no regrets no I mean it's
not easy to go to a military academy
it's not only your rigorous academic
schedule it's all the other stuff too
builds character the character to push
through challenges a trait that serves
kori who is now deployed and flying mq-9
reaper z' what's it like to fly drones
over the Middle East and then be able to
go home and have dinner with your family
in South Dakota I really enjoy my
mission I got a great family supporting
me and were there doing a good cause so
I think a lot of people can hold on to
that and know that there's a there's a
reason for what we do so how proud are
you I'm very proud of these girls the
only thing I wish is that their
grandpa's could have seen been alive to
see them graduate the academies yeah yes
they would have been so proud and it
just it breaks both of our hearts didn't
it mm-hmm
you get choked up saying that mm-hmm why
I mean Luke's death has to wait and hope
for and mine was in her way and it just
it really would have been good Stacy's
father bill Pelphrey helped discover a
secret network of tunnels the Vietcong
were using during the Vietnam War and we
have a clip for you oh and what's so
interesting to be able to discover on 60
minutes this clip of Bill and the other
so-called tunnel rats
we found bodies buried in tunnels quite
a few times but you only report it once
because some intelligence officer is
gonna tell you to dig him out and see
what killed him as my daddy is so funny
he had this Kentuckian twanging even
though he always claimed being from
Tulsa Oklahoma did you guys know it was
on 60 minutes no from the grandfathers
to the trio of sisters the fourth
generation
of Easter's to serve in the military no
one has paid the ultimate sacrifice
dying in the line of duty
Madi is in an irregular warfare unit do
you worry about her being deployed not
yet she says two more years here so not
yet what do you think Manny
I think Wiles come to whether the the
best Academy if not to train to help and
do the purpose that we were here for
course that's new you know in the last
few years having women in combat and
it's just we saw and heard about this
story and I said I got to meet these
three women who've gone to all three
military academies and their parents you
know because the idea of service serve a
selfless sacrifice to your country I
think it is one that we all need to hear
more about you know we need to hear
people don't even start
yeah yes and what a great family I love
when dad got a little touch talking
about his day I looked over at his wife
and then she immediately started talking
then for you to pull out that 60 minutes
clip I know to know that your
grandfather was every night 16 minutes
right the easter-egg helpfulness meet
the Easter sister yeah thank you
this morning's profiles in service
sponsored by the Boeing Company